salehi aujourd'hui on est mardi le mardi
je fais un tour quand quelqu'un a un
truc ensemble fut faut forcément charme
volontaires désignés un volontaire
désigné avec moi et c'était de voir
qu'on puisse
bonjour et comme c'est un producteur de
spectacles produits les coûts de
l'humour et plein d'autres choses et il
est venu à la maison il est aujourd'hui
une grande nouvelle gamme anniversaire
un anniversaire vraiment que je voudrais
souhaiter
tous les anniversaires alstom est en
revanche parvenue à 5% auparavant un
cheptel de guinée équatoriale manque
l'or c'est un domaine où les repères
je suis allé chez un pote qui étaient
appelés à faire des siennes on pouvait
regarder 24 heures sur 24
et puis on est arrivé à rien
après ce passage et dès qu'il se passe
un truc intéressant qu'une main au pot
de fleurs qui s'attache à l'époque ils
ont lancé le concept de secret story
les trente-huit mille personnes qui
voulaient participer à un truc
alors qu'il savait pas ce que c'était
il ya eu 13 été sélectionnés 2 qui
était parti très très vite d'ailleurs
après c'est très intéressant ce qui
est vidé devenu chroniqueur
loana
abyei alors que monte la vente
de sorte que son étoile devenu
consultant artistique dans un hôtel
cinq étoiles ils ont tous fait un truc
après quelques problèmes par
l'arrière 4 à l'arrière dans le stade
tu fais partie des 38 villes qui passe
le casting des sélectionnés et le
quatorzième candidats
et tu fais affaire c'est 70 jours
dans le loft
cette étude piscine c'est triste peu à
peu en place
recul à la piscine mauvais quand vous
voulez mais vous avez tort parce que
quelque 70 jours heureux il se passe des
choses peut dire pas grand-chose ne
s'est pas passé grand-chose dans le
loft semblerait qu'il a pu j'aurais tort
comme bruxelles veut dire que j'adore
claude et leurs complices 15 ans après
le loft je vous retrouve ici chez moi
pour le moral de la ville on se souvient
de votre sortie tv exceptionnel
c'était sur les champs-élysées c'est
ça s'appuyer sur l'écran l'histoire
comme le sait que sarko et ses
parcomètres et il est là avec mort
puisque cette chance-là
la police s'est bien passé la sortie du
loft
c'est un peu la folie
outre les paparazzi
on se souvient on vous a vu à peu près
égales par points s'est montré plus
préoccupé comment bout de ligne par
bout avait dû reprendre un métier
j'aimerais maintenant que tu n'imagines
le métier
différé après la place par certains
de ses membres comptent dans le tour
préliminaire
t'imagines le métier que je crois
qu'après notre combat producteurs parce
que c'est ce que je fais maintenant mais
tu peux prendre mon sens importe quoi au
fait sané de taxidermiste un chauffeur
de bus le plus important tata le métier
en tête
le métier que tu après le loft
celle qui est déjà fait pour de vrai
oui pourquoi pas s'arrêter fin de
saison dans pater est à saluer les ai
pas trouvés
affaire assez simple
heureusement je connais pas ta vie donc
je sais pas exactement ce que quelqu'un
comme comme job par contre ne peut
acheter
les plus inédites imaginées
en situation
le toit imagine-toi dit ne pas être en
train de pratiquer ce métier est-ce que
le fait de croiser les bras voilà tu
t'imagines juste en train de pratiquer
une action que nécessite ce métier
imagine fort des choses dans la pièce
victoire parce que le film de cimetière
d'accord que chacun plusieurs endroits
différents
obtiennent donc ça se fasse plus tôt
dans une grande salle c'est pas dans un
bureau
c'est vrai -avi
tata atteindra d'enlisement donc sa
maison mouvementée de gros permanence
est correct
avant l'attaqué
emc s
que
est-ce que je reste optimiste
je pense avoir une piste le regarde pas
ce que j'écris et regarde justice et la
caméra moi je peux l'écrire ici
pourquoi
je pense qu'il faut c'est ça est-ce que
tu peux me dire quel métier tu as
choisi
pour s'en défaire après celle
historique actuelle
elle décide de le savoir
ces revers
cerbère
trois prochaines années surtout dans le
port de la c'est vrai
en même temps au plus offrant
leur approche comme toujours dans la
tourmente de francs
à l'inversé ses lecteurs
c'est frustrant mais le fait de ne pas
faire
j'adore voir les quelques recettes que
l'afinitor
merci à toi d'avoir participé merci
beaucoup devant le peu d'expérience si
les devancent largement demande ce que
son poste à la fin ne cherchez pas à
comprendre c'est pas le but de cette
vidéo le but de cette vidéo c'est
déjà de vous divertir moi de sortir un
nouveau toit et de faire sortir
quelqu'un merci à toi un homme tu fais
des coudes les manches complètes dans
le descriptif le lien pour les coûts de
dose d'humour c'est un plateau
d'artistes si cette mobilisation sur un
hors-jeu plus vous pouvez nous le faire
savoir un but d'audel d'ormesson un
petit tout sens là et a beaucoup ri
également vous abonner à la chaîne
vous pouvez laisser un petit commentaire
et grands se retrouvent demain à 17
heures pour le prochain mandat le blog
korben